hey guys and welcome back to the Le P
show today we have a really amazing
guest there is so much happening in the
crypto space right now we need an update
we need to sort of navigate through what
is happening so joining me on the show
today we have a major crypto YouTuber
he's an educator an investor in over a
hundred different crypto startups so I'm
really happy to have a virtual bacon on
the show welcome how are
you great uh great to be here and thank
you for having me also it's great to
have you there's just so much going on
in the space right now um you know it
looks like we have this pending bull
market coming nobody really knows you
know whether we're going to actually
crash down even further so I'd be really
Keen just to get your take on where you
think we're at in the market cycle right
now um you know obviously we have the
spot ETF coming very soon so what's your
take are you bullish right now or you
still quite playing it quite
cautious I personally I'm definitely
bullish so I think we're getting to that
point of the market Cycles where if you
even if you like to follow the fouryear
Cycles now is about the best time right
before the having event when most people
are still in the disbelief stage from
the r audience but uh people that have
been around for a couple Cycles like are
starting to get in very heavily uh and I
think the fundamentals uh the events
coming up in the next year is also very
very clear of uh the timeline and their
potential effects and obviously we have
the Bitcoin spot ETF um coming out in
the US very soon so I'm curious what's
your take how do you think that's going
to affect the market if it's going to
affect the market at
all I think uh there's a lot of
misconceptions out there also around
this people say that all the ETF um has
been around across the globe even for
spot ETF for Bitcoin but I think there's
a major difference between when that's
launched in the US market versus other
markets so uh yes I would say outside of
us maybe it's a little bit more it but
really the the true big money comes from
Wall Street comes from uh trafi and they
need this kind of regulated instrument
with uh trustworthy custodian and just
in a market that they can play with so I
think it will have a major effect now um
us as crypto native investors we are
definitely small fish compared to these
guys so I think uh whether you know the
cycle will play out exactly like we
predict that's going to be harder to say
um these guys might come in and play
their own games but I think long-term
definitely bullish for Bitcoin uh in
terms of adoption and uh you know
potential new money coming in when do
you think the spot ETF will be approved
coinex one of the leading Global
cryptocurrency exchanges is celebrating
its sixth anniversary and to mark this
event they've got some incredible
campaigns and events lined up just for
you the exchange is offering huge prizes
of up to 186 usdt for each new user so
if you are new to the crypto world this
is the perfect opportunity for you to
Kickstart your journey to claim your
newbie bonus and dive into the world of
crypto with coinex simply click on the
link in the description below and
there's more coinex is not stopping
there on December 18th they are
launching the future tradeboard where
you can join and share a whopping
$20,000 click on the link in the
description to participate in the future
tradeboard event it's a chance to
Showcase your trading skills and to be a
part of an amazing celebration and also
don't forget to check out the other
incredible events campaigns coinex has
install for a sixth anniversary
celebration you can find all the details
by visiting the anniversary Link in the
description I like to play safe on this
uh prediction so I think um so the
latest deadline that I've seen is March
next year which is uh when black rocks
application and all other applications
are kind of within one week so I and and
based on previous rejections from SEC on
these ETFs they usually take the maximum
24-day range so that will lead us right
into March next year so I think I'm
personally waiting for March that's I
think we will have it for sure now a lot
of people are saying oh end of this year
Etc that could happen uh but I think we
have already seen quite a bit of fake
news coming up with you know Market
chopping up and then coming back down
again so I think it's a definitely
harder to say and I think from now until
March it's only five months away so
between two months and five months
rather play safe so myself personally
I'm betting on March next year yeah I
agree with you I think you know we we've
had so much happen this year that it it
feels that it would only make sense for
it to come in the new year it would be
too much of a rush to squeeze it in
before the year ends um yeah that's my
take yeah and I mean Black Rock these
guys like to take their time to really
use the news hover you know to their
best advantage and so I don't know if if
it will be just like everyone says um
end of this year it's just going to
happen but do you think it's going to be
a buy the rumor sell the news event
because that's so much of what we see in
crypto um where a lot of the things are
priced in um you know especially when
you have like blockchain upgrades and
things like that updates to different
networks when the network is updated the
price doesn't do what everybody says
it's going to do it really is a buy the
room or sell the news event so do you
think that the spot ETF will be the
same I think uh I think potentially yes
not longterm but I think uh there's kind
of two sides to it first there's what
black rocks needs to do leading up to
the launch of the ETF so they have to
get things approved they have to see the
ETF make their purchases that's going to
be the initial kind of driver uh real
liquidity driver and I think that most
likely have already happened because
we're only a couple months away so now
uh once the news comes out well if they
need some initial liquidity back from
that maybe there's going to be a sell
news happening right after but then once
uh the ETF actually launches when black
Rock's clients can come in I think
that's more of a long-term game and um I
don't think that's going to be right
away when the ETF gets approved within
one month so uh yeah that's why I think
probably March april-ish there's going
to be decent volatility and I don't
think it's going to just straight up
shoot to alltime high or anything like
that um yeah so definitely still being
cautious yeah no I I I have a very
similar opinion um you know I I don't
think it's priced in necessarily um but
I do think that simply just because of
how scar Bitcoin is anyway there's only
you know ever going to be 21 million um
and you know all these major
institutions having to buy up Bitcoin is
going to really take a hit on the supply
like I think it's going to be naturally
a scarcity event um and so I I think
it's going to be really fascinating to
see but I agree with you I think you
know it's not going to be um straight
away it's going to it's going to have a
l a much slower but a much more
impactful long-term um impact in the
long term I
think yeah I think we should see a lot
more you know Fortune 500 companies get
into Bitcoin with our treasuries but
that's not going to take like overnight
even with the new EF so you know what's
funny I'm having so many debates with
people right now um about where we are
in the in in the market and I do agree
with you I'm also extremely bullish
right now because I'm a strong believer
in the fouryear Cycles so obviously we
have the Bitcoin harving coming soon but
so many people are telling me that they
think that we're going to crash one last
time so I'm curious do you think that
all the bad news is behind us I mean
literally this time last year um almost
we had the FDX crash um we had block
five Celsius Luna it's pretty bad what
happened to crypto uh investors so do
you think it's behind us
yeah I think so
I don't think the cycle will be so
smooth because usually during kind of
this last stage of the bare Market
there's kind of one event uh that causes
the market to crash a bit more uh and I
think this time around there are some
potential you know head ones that could
come up there's a lot of you know uh
speculation around binance around tether
a lot of industrywide news and I think
the time window between now until the
ETF gets approved and the having happens
is uh something could happen I I I am I
am in that camp now is it going to be
like a Black Swan event where it crashes
you know make a new low like previous
Cycles that's going to be bit harder
because we already have had major
crashes so this Cycle's lows were really
very uh very extreme because of FTX
because of Luna so I'm in a camp that
kind of bottom is already in but bumpy
roads will continue to play from now
until let's say April next year yeah I I
share the same view actually um I mean
we just have to look at 20 uh 2019 and
2020 we thought the bottom was in at 3K
and then obviously Co happened the world
locked down in March 2020 and then
Bitcoin obviously crashed 50% down to 4K
but it recovered very quickly so that's
what that's what I'm really open to in
this cycle like I think we're going to
have another crash just because the
world is so volatile right now like we
have wars going on in Europe War in the
midle Le on the brink of World War II so
I think you know from like a macro pers
perspective everything is extremely
volatile so I wouldn't be surprised if
we do see that crash however I expect a
v-shaped recovery like we saw in
2020 I think you know I think it's
really going to be more of a strong
volatility in the market than a very
likely crash for sure so another
scenario that people have proposed
against the sort of smooth for your
cycle starting
is uh for black C to coming in and
potentially bring Bitcoin towards new
alltime high even before the kind of
having cycle happens and then price
comes dropping back down again really
mess people's you know psychology up the
people that follow these Cycles too
quickly so I think something like that
could even happen and I just think you
know yeah it it's going to mess people
psyche up really uh and honestly uh now
that the tra guys are in you know is it
going to follow exactly like the
fouryear cycle I think that's that's the
real question here that could still have
more volatility uh so yeah I think it's
more about looking kind of one to two
years ahead at least and in order to
avoid this last period of of like buy
yeah I think you know if um blackw were
to get the ETF approved before the
harving um you know it's a matter of
just looking at what Bitcoin does and
looking at what the price price does
because if it looks like that kick
starts a bull market well then you you
have to look at it like it's a bull
market in the as if the harving has just
happened and then and then sort of like
take it from there and count you know
the next like 18 months from there
rather than counting it from uh when the
the Haring happens because that's
initially how how people look at those
Cycles yeah people tend to look at like
six months after the having usually it
it really starts to kick off like the
Christmas after the having but now we
are still quite a bit earlier than that
so if it starts even before or right
after the half yeah the timeline will be
all so just take take profits basically
just just just take profits yeah take
profit think long term and yeah no
exactly um you have on your Twitter um
on your X bio that you've invested in
over 100 crypto projects so what do you
bullish on for the next upcoming bull
market
then
so I think uh I think some sectors are
definitely making a comeback and some
are way too overplayed so I think the
ethereum killers to layer ones are
definitely way overplayed now that's
going to be heavily transitioned into
layer twos even layer twos are a little
bit um the leaders are definitely
leading I think you know things like
arbitrum polygon optimism these guys
will continue to do well uh but I think
if you're still running a layer one I'm
kind of bearish on them unless you have
a very strong unique vertical that
cannot be replicated on
ethereum uh so that's one side and then
I think crypto gaming is really it has
had a very extended be run now uh that I
think it it will make a comeback uh both
in terms of the timing of these games
that just went into development around
2020 is it's finally becoming ready to
have first wave of compatible games uh
that are uh you know pretty impressive
even in the web two players eyes and
then you have the infrastructure stuff
that's uh actually focusing on real
adoption this time instead of you know
all
the gamify defi stuff that that happened
last cycle so I think longterm yeah
still bullish on crypto gaming um and
then I think last one would be more
decentralized web or decentralized
social media or just overall something
that um harder to censor and harder to
manipulate uh in terms of like online
information and how people you know
perceive other perceive others and
interact with others I think that's a
big Trend that is very naturally
building up and the clear solution here
is blockchain is crypto and I think
that's one area that people could pretty
easily get into yeah no that makes a lot
of sense um I I also agree just because
we've seen so much censorship over the
last few years and I think people are
just just tired of it you know they
people want a solution desperately um
but but it's interesting because every
bull market I've noticed has its thing
it has its boom whether it's like icos
whe whether it's the defi summer nfts
the metaverse so if you could pick one
thing that's going to be the you know
have the the hype in the next ball run
what do you think it's going to be or do
you think it hasn't even been invented
yet so I think there's two that the
narrative side is well the few that I'm
bullish on but I think the core kind of
technology or way for people to
speculate on these instruments uh I
don't think that has been invented so we
have had a few of these like you said
iOS in 2017 then we had um def5 farming
in in late 2019 early 2020 we even had
nfts I think you could definitely count
that mining the nfts trading them AC
between each other that's another
speculative instrument that was
technically I I think it was an
invention um that was able to collect
Capital very quickly so I think either
we recycle the old ones and kind of
tweak them a little bit it just becomes
Ico 3.0 or something else gets invented
and I think there's kind of a this cycle
Define moment I think frch something
like that is interesting it was kind of
showing the early signs of that yeah but
um how their economics are designed a
little bit too aggressive for the team
so yeah that makes a lot of sense I'm
curious about AI um you know I thought
perhaps AI would be the next thing um I
know I don't actually have the stats off
the top of my head but I know that a lot
of crypto projects that integrate AI are
doing extremely well so for example if
you have some kind of like AI trading
bot or something you know which um
integrates AI then it's doing extremely
well but I I don't think that that's
going to be the next boom you know I
think a boom in crypto has to be really
native to to crypto right like it can't
be something using crypto like AI
everyone gets it this is the next Ico
next D5 Farm you can clearly calculate
your your ins and out the returns yeah
it has to be related to yeah the trading
bot stuff is interesting I think it's um
it's tapping into a definitely more much
more mobile audience and you can trade
on this chat interface on telegram
Discord uh that's and there are sides of
that that
um kind of unlocked different ways of
trading on dexus I think when people you
know snipe these new tokens uh with the
trading Bots I think that's a pretty
novel concept that wasn't around even in
2021 when defi was first popular it was
really a kind of an experts game like
you had to be a coder before to do it
but now pretty much everyone can do it
uh just with these trading bots so uh
right now it's still a power users game
but you the barrier to entry is much
lower so that kind of resembles how like
defi is uh in late 2019 uh where people
could start to get into like new defi
tokens if you just knew how to play with
uh the right app on your metamask so
yeah something could go towards that
direction uh yeah okay well interesting
and I kind of want to get your take on
um nfts because nfts went crazy um you
know I think some of the board a Yacht
Club uh so some of those pieces were
going from like 150 to 300 eth um at the
top of the market and I've seen Elon
Musk speak about it uh recently and he
actually thinks it's dead the nft market
so what do you think do you think the
nft market is dead do you think it will
uh recover do you think we'll see you
know those highs of like 300 eth for for
an
nft so 300 eth is definitely way
overextended and
yeah it will be hard uh for that kind of
market cap to come back now I I
personally do like board Apes at least
there's only a handful of nfts that I
think could make a comeback if nft
Market gets liquidity back in again so I
like board Apes I like the few like
Community run projects I think um stuff
that's you know fairly launched uh or
things that have like relatively good
adoption even in the bare Market without
having to large amounts of money uh for
example the the py Penguins I think
they're pretty interesting how you know
this guy lucanet he just came in with
his own Capital took over the project
and then brought it to Walmart with a
partnership without raising large
amounts of funds I think that's pretty
interesting um but overall nft Market
stats definitely dead right now um most
projects you know if they are uh this is
kind of what I consult people as well
like if you're trying to launch an nft
even if it makes sense in your platform
in your game I would kind of push them
towards launching token instead for now
because pretty much for the past year no
n good mfts have launched and remain
higher than their launch price so yeah
the interest is just not there um I
think a large reason is because too much
of too many of these projects they they
took the easy way out of uh at the peak
of the nft market a lot of these top
leading projects they went to the VC
route they raised large amounts of funds
from VC capital and then they are forced
to deliver so by delivering essentially
the easiest way for them is to just
continue to milk their brand and issue
more and more uh you know sub Brands
under their collection diluting the
current Supply and raising ethereum
through minting so that's just it makes
sense for them makes sense for the VCS
but completely kills the market because
people just very quickly realize oh it's
a raising money game nothing actually
gets delivered yeah well you know
speaking of getting things delivered and
looking for those amazing projects which
we're all trying to do you you must get
offered you know a lot of projects to
either invest in to talk about to
promote I mean I know I do my my DMs are
flooded um but I'm curious how do you
know if a project is serious how do you
know if it's legit what are your green
flags in a project and then what are
your red flags in a
project so I think the best green flag
would be the founder if you know the
founder if you have a direct friend that
you absolutely trust and he trust them
they are close friends you can meet them
in real life you know where they live
that kind of stuff then it's uh life
that's the strongest life is on the line
yes um you know they're dos to you they
know you you know them uh and you can
you can get a sense of the guy right
they are in this for a reason um and I
think in the bare Market uh the founder
really drives whether the project
survives or not if they can persevere
and conserve their capital and not spend
too much and focus on what really
matters and I think also in the bare
Market there are a lot more legit
Founders because this this period is
less froy so people are usually in this
for a reason
um aside from that you know um previous
track record I think if you
have I would say even made mistakes
before but you still choose to come back
that still kind of is is a bet on the
founder but previous
experience
um and yeah and aside from that like
more kind of soft skills so managing a
team and really knowing how to manage
your money managing your treasury when
when you're raising that money like do
you you have a
clear uh burn rate and where you plan to
spend these funds I think that's way
more important than a lot of things
people consider like people look at the
ideas too much and the how quickly they
can build this Tech but to a lot of it
is timing so if you can't last till the
bull market it doesn't matter um yeah no
that's that's a really good point
yeah
yeah uh yeah red flags I I don't know
like in the Market it it's it's a good
time to to talk to people because people
are usually yeah they're more
committed anything else you want to add
or you feel like those those are the
main red and green flags um let's
see
so red flags I have personally like
stuff that I have experienced if
the there are things that definitely are
super important in a Founder so if they
don't know how to communicate
uh properly I think that's probably top
two ref fls uh either communicating with
with your investors with your community
with your team of you know how who takes
who takes each part uh I think that's
way more important than people realize
um even if you're amazing coder I've
seen so many times where you have just
one guy that can code everything nobody
understands it I think so much of it is
getting like the knowledge out there and
kind of a crowd understanding of what
your thing is and even the investors
understanding what you're trying to do
so yeah my number one ref like with me
would be not knowing how to communicate
not knowing how to how to talk to people
gotcha and I'm really curious what's
your long-term view on bitcoin versus
altcoin so do you see one being more
safe than the other if so how safe do
you plan on playing it so for example
say that you uh had to hold Bitcoin or
another type of crypto for 10 years like
do you feel more comfortable holding it
in Bitcoin holding it in altcoins what's
your outlook
like
so uh Bitcoin is really showing itself
even uh especially in the this like 2024
run because of Black Rock coming in ETC
it's very hard for these guys to go into
altcoins uh they have even kind of soft
hinted that oh we are into Bitcoin this
proof of um what's the word that he said
lry think um fly to Quality you know and
and he like has a very few things he
they're they're excited about at Wall
Street so I think long-term Bitcoin is
still the very easy play that will
continue to grow and dominate the crypto
Market uh regardless like the pure like
market cap um potential of Bitcoin is
not really too limited uh you can say
the same for ethereum I think ethereum
is kind of at that breaking point where
if you know black raw comes in and says
we also hold ethereum very similar
status to bitcoin it's a commodity then
it becomes kind of a public good it's no
longer a start a tech startup right an
asset class instead but for the rest of
the altcoins I think in the last cycle
so many altcoins got way too big we're
talking about like 200 300 billion
dollar in market cap for the largest
altcoins and that's very much pushing
the largest market caps of the biggest
companies in the world so I think in
this cycle while Bitcoin does its you
know 6X or whatever ideal can these top
altcoins reach $1 trillion dollar market
cap I think that's
a hard question to say I think um
there's I think there's a higher chance
that we continue to get alquin that top
out maybe at 100 to 200 billion Max
market cap but we just have many more of
them uh or the market just extends to so
many different sub sectors with smaller
coins uh so that the overall industry
grows um so in that sense I think
Bitcoin
ethereum actually much safer bets uh for
from now until we know exactly how
crypto is treated as asset class um
because they're very different Bitcoin
ethereum are very different from startup
altcoins uh there's a kind of a
valuation cap that it's very hard to get
over that kind of just touches on my
next question which is really just about
like your overall outlook on regulation
in the US so yeah it looks like Bitcoin
you know is digital property um ethereum
I think seems pretty safe from being
called a security what do you think
about the other old coins do you think
they'll be deemed to security obviously
xrp seems to have won the case so yeah
like do you think they're they're all
going to be okay or do you think there's
going to be alternative ways that the
government is able to crack down on
crypto so I think the security question
is really yeah I think it's one of the
fundamental reasons why we saw so many
ethereum killers is because ethereum was
kind of cleared so people wanted to
launch etherum Killers because they knew
that for a few years it was okay similar
to like
these Bitcoin Forks like Bitcoin cash
was popular most mostly because Bitcoin
was okay and yeah so I think now that
xrp has been cleared um sort of if if we
see the whole thing being resolved I I
think we're likely to see it uh we could
potentially see payment coins being
pretty well utilized like you know coins
that act as um kind of utility tokens in
a payment nowk n work that connect
different liquidity from different you
know currencies Etc and assets that's
one area that I think is pretty
interesting uh aside from that I don't
know if there are any other non-bitcoin
or ethereum Forks that have been cleared
so uh until that happens I think it's
kind of still pretty risky and uh yeah
especially in in this run when the
institutions come in it's going to be a
hard definitely I mean we're seeing it
play out right now um so I'm curious
then we we have this bull market coming
but what are you currently working on
between now and the bull market like
what what are you focused on right
now so I'm just trying to one side is
YouTube you know I love making videos so
just trying to make as much content as
possible and really getting my brain
like getting my you know constant
information sources in check so that I
know what's happening following up with
the market uh that's probably 607 70% of
my time uh and then the other side is
just actually talking to talking to
teams talking to new Founders and uh
making sure that like even even though
the kind of new projects and and VC
funding space isn't so hot yet don't
want to lose touch uh so whatever people
are working on constantly talking to
them like I probably take average like
five calls a week with with teams
pitching uh it'll only get more but um
yeah so doing that
and just trying to trying to be prepared
because things are only going to get
more more hectic they are going to get
so hectic and I'm excited I think we
desperately need a bull market we need
some bullish news um we need to we need
better sentiment you know like like
Krypto Twitter has been dead for a good
two years now we need yeah two years of
touching grass it's two years of
touching grass that's what I'm saying
it's time to come back well it's been
such a pleasure having you on the show
today where can people follow you um and
stay up to date with everything that
you're
doing so uh you can find me on YouTube
virtual bacon I'm also Super Active on
Twitter X virtual bacon
ZX uh and also we have you know all of
our links on virtual.com you know you
can find all my other communities on
there well thank you thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure having you on
um and I'm super excited for this bull
market and I'm excited to see you know
your content evolve as the as the market
continues to pump so thanks so much for
coming on it's been
great yeah thanks for having me great
talk